tenemos dos líneas paralelas el segmento
de línea ave y el segmento de línea sede
son segmentos de líneas paralelas luego
tenemos estas transversales que las
cortan a las paralelas la transversal bc
y la transversal a d y lo que nos dice
este diagrama es que la distancia de a
es esta marca
dice que ese segmento mide lo mismo que
el segmento f tienen la misma distancia
otra manera de pensarlo es que el punto
es el punto medio del segmento ave y en
este vídeo la gran pregunta es la
siguiente el punto es también punto
medio del segmento b c esa es la
pregunta entonces la voy a poner aquí
escribo
y el punto medio del segmento b c y
entonces basándote en los vídeos que he
hecho anteriores a este quizás se te
ocurra que esto tiene que ver con
congruencia de triángulos veamos si
podemos establecer congruencia entre los
triángulos que tenemos en este diagrama
tenemos este triángulo el de la
izquierda y tenemos el triángulo de la
derecha el de la izquierda parece que
apunta hacia arriba el de la derecha
parece que apunta hacia abajo ahora hay
muchas cosas que sabemos acerca de
ángulos verticales y ángulos de
transversales el ángulo obvio de este
asunto es el ángulo a b sabemos que este
va a ser congruente con el ángulo c este
entonces sabemos lo siguiente que el
ángulo
b es congruente con el ángulo de s
entonces el ángulo ave es congruente con
el ángulo de s lo que significa
básicamente que tienen la misma medida y
sabemos eso porque son ángulos
verticales o sea son un par de ángulos
opuestos uno del otro
formados por dos líneas que se
intersectan sabemos lo siguiente sabemos
qué ave y se ve son segmentos paralelos
y bc es una transversal que las corta
entonces sabemos que esta es una
transversal y varias maneras de pensar
lo voy a continuar aquí la transversal y
las paralelas para ver con más claridad
todos los ángulos distintos que tenemos
podemos decir lo siguiente podemos decir
que el ángulo ave es aquí está su medida
ave
es alterno interno al ángulo s de este
de aquí y si no se te ocurrió eso dirías
que el ángulo correspondiente a este es
el ángulo de aquí arriba si
continuáramos esta línea
estos son ángulos correspondientes y
este es vertical pero de cualquier
manera el ángulo ave este va a ser
congruente con el ángulo de ce es por
ser ángulos alternos internos el ángulo
ave es congruente con el ángulo dese o
sea están entre las paralelas a distinto
lado de ellas y a distinto lado de la
transversal bc esto por ser ángulos
alternos internos esa es la definición
lo pongo aquí de manera abreviada
ángulos alternos internos
ahora tenemos una relación interesante
tenemos un ángulo congruente a otro esté
congruente a este y este este otro
también tenemos dos lados congruentes
entonces tenemos rosa verde el lado rosa
verde el lado y de aquí podemos aplicar
el criterio de confluencia de triángulos
y el ángulo ángulo lado ahora ya tenemos
el triángulo veamos si tenemos en
excelencia los correspondientes vértices
con sus letras respectivas en orden
podemos decir que el triángulo o bueno
mejor mejor inicio con el ángulo b para
hacerlo más interesante entonces inició
con el rosa después al centro y al que
no tiene nombre pongo el triángulo b
es congruente otra vez voy al rosa se
después del centro
y el que no tiene nombre de esto por aa
él y también porque corresponde en rosa
verde lado rosa verde lado todos son
congruentes esto por ángulo ángulo lado
entonces esto es por a y el ángulo
ángulo lado y sabemos que son
congruentes esto significa que los lados
correspondientes son congruentes luego
sabemos que estos dos triángulos son
congruentes
eso significa que sus lados
correspondientes son congruentes por lo
tanto la medida debe el segmento entre
los ángulos rosa y verde el segmento b
tiene la misma medida que su lado
correspondiente c
entre los ángulos rosa y verde por lo
tanto b es igual hace a los enumeramos
todo sale de el 3 de aquí queda
demostrado es el punto medio del
segmento bc genial entonces puedo marcar
aquí con doble raya este segmento de
línea es con frente con este otro
segmento de línea porque sabemos que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes
ahora nótese que hice mi prueba de dos
columnas aquí por un lado tengo mis
declaraciones y del otro lado tengo la
razón
y terminamos hasta pronto